I'm Uta Francke, I'm a human geneticist originally from
Germany as you can hear. And I'm Emeritus Professor here
at Stanford and also Senior Medical Director at 23
and Me. You know there were early estimates of the
size of the genome simply by the, measuring the
amount of DNA in a cell. People could do that
a long time ago. And so the estimate was
in that range of 3 billion base pairs, but the
idea to actually sequence it was, came up
in the mid 80s when capillary sequencing was
developed, and many people thought it was a
absolutely crazy idea because it's so huge, so
much information. The other thing to know about
the Human Genome Project, when it finally got
started around 1990, the first five years were
devoted to just mapping the chromosomes. You know,
people heard about chromosomes, and we know that
DNA runs in chromosomes from one end to another,
so it would make sense, logical sense to start
sequencing at one end and then go through. But
instead what people did they made maps of the
chromosomes. And then you could focus in on specific
regions and do the sequencing there. And also to
find genes that are located in specific chromosomal regions.
>> I see. So instead of having to, sort of like you say,
sequence from one end to the other you could have many starting
places in the middle of a chromosome and read out from there?
>> Right. And you could relate
the sequence to the chromosomal features because
chromosomes when they are treated with
a certain agents display banding patterns that
are very unique. Therefore we can
identify each chromosome individually. Which is something
you cannot do when they are uniformly stained. And also we can see within
each chromosome there are certain regions. And now
we can find out in which region certain genes
are located. And all of this physical mapping as
it's called, was done before the sequencing even started.
>> So what happened when the sequencing project
started? You mentioned it was an international collaboration
Was this really countries all over the world
or were they more from one region or another?
>> Well they were countries who had developed
infrastructure to take on such a big project. And
in Europe it was predominantly the U.K., France,
and Germany, and Canada was a player, as well
as Japan and China. And all of these
people got together under the chairmanship, so to say,
of Francis Collins, who is now the director of
the NIH. He was organizing this big international thing.
And made sure there wasn't too much waste and duplication. They were dividing up
the chromosome. Sarka, you do chromosome 21.
Okay, that's where we are focusing on.
And then they had regular meetings, they
exchanged information. All the results were immediately
shared and put online, and therefore because
of this international effort. this led to success.
>> Where are we now with sequencing the human
genome or many human genomes? Are we multiple
drafts beyond and are we reaching out to many
people. The international effort had many different people
involved. So the genome is a composite of sequences
of many individuals. And that's called the reference
genome. But what you really want to know is,
what is different between the genomes of different
people who live in different parts of the world.
And that was the next effort, and to really sequence individuals
with known ethnic background and find out what are the variations
between humans, and that's when it really became interesting, and that
took another ten years to become really useful to have that information.
>> What does the size of the genome mean? Does it mean anything at all?
>> Well, there were some organisms with huge
genomes, like the salamanders, you know? And what is
all that sequence? It probably has no informational content.
Sometimes genomes get big because viruses get in, and
they replicate, they make copies of themselves, and
that has no useful function. So there was only
a smaller part of the genome that is really
important because it has function and this is something
we are still working on, unraveling the functions.
>> You also mentioned repetitive DNA when you were talking about some of, I
guess the historical context of the genome and even once we sequence it if
anyone does any research on their own, they might find that there is a
still lot of repetitive region. What do we know about those in the genome?
>> In most of them are just remnants, I
mean there were copies made of some early viral
intruder and now they are degenerated that bits and
pieces of them, but there are still some active
copies and what they can do, they can still
make copies of themselves. And they can jump around, and
insert somewhere else in the genome, and actually cause
problems. They can cause disease, by inserting into an important
protein coding gene. So, we are not done with
dealing with all of these repetitive sequences. They're still changing.
And that means there was huge variability from one person to another as well.
>> I think that's an amazing concept too, to think about our
genomes. We sort of them as, okay, we have this static genome.
>> Right.
>> And it may interact with itself to create a protein or
regulation, but the genome itself is changing even today, like you said
>> Quite
>> Moving elements.
>> It's still evolving.